this morning speeches highlighted those
sacrifices of the troops who took part
in the invasion we've heard many
personal stories from the veterans who
are here today Mark Phillips has cover
old several of these D Day ceremonies
mark what makes this anniversary so
special well the very fact that this is
the 75th and so if you were a young
soldier around the age of 20 as most of
them were coming ashore on that day 75
years ago you're well into your 90s now
some of them into their late nineties
and this could well be the last time
this kind of living history can return
here to have the experience and provide
the lessons that an event like this
provides it's interesting because it may
be the last time in surprisingly for
some of these veterans it's actually the
first time they've been here since since
the invasion it's very emotional for
them isn't it it is I mean some have
come back several times some you do hear
for the first time getting on in years
wanting their children and particularly
their grandchildren to know not just
their personal story but the
significance of what took place here and
not just the sacrifice and the heroisms
but the heroism but also the history is
during the ceremony we saw one veteran
stand up out of think a wheelchair to
hug President Trump yeah you know this
how important is it this event to
veterans do you think well on the
evidence of that pretty a pretty
important
private first class Russell Pickett he
was from my land at Omaha Beach he was
wounded three times once in the first
wave was sent back to the hospital came
back six days later was wounded again
was wounded a third time later in the
battle in France and is the the last
survivor it seems of company a that
landed on the beaches here that day
there were a number of there were a
number of veterans who were singled out
today both by President McCraw and by
President Trump
in talking in talking to these veterans
in the last few days what what strikes
you most about them I think the the fact
that they they've long ago come to terms
with what happened here and now they're
dealing with kind of the significance in
their lives here
you know the a lot of them went back
home started their families had their
job started businesses and what happened
but it's now occurring to them as it
would late in your approaching a hundred
years old that this was probably a
seminal moment in in their lives yeah
and I was talking to Jake Larson who
will hear from later in this show and
and he said the thing that keeps coming
back to me is how lucky I was to leave
here you know seeing so many of his
colleagues who are buried here behind us
and I think that's a sentiment a lot of
these guys here love can you hear
everything you know you guys were heroes
the guys are heroes and to a man they
will tell you know we're not the heroes
yeah people in these great people behind
us are Gail it's yeah it is a sentiment
that it's shared just about universally
by the veterans here I keep hearing and
you know true heroes never say you know
I'm a hero
this is what strikes me about all of the
this is what strikes me really about all
of his men these men you talk about how
emotional it is for the men it's
emotional for everybody who's just
watching on television to hear their
stories and to see that what you have to
say to them you know to a tee what do
you find that they have in common is
that their grit is that their courage is
it their candor what is it I'll take
that one
Thanks all those things Gail but but
it's it's also it's what Mark said it's
it's none of none of them everybody says
we had a job to do it's it's almost the
first answer you get from
every one of these veterans you talk to
no matter how heroic they were on the
day none of them want to take credit and
they want to give that credit to the
people they knew they left behind and
and they're all very conscious of that
that they were lucky enough to lead
their lives and have families I think
pride is the word that you often hear
coming up and not just pride in what
they did but pride in what their unit
the the the band of brothers phrase on
so often I mention Jake Larson this is
this bed I spoke to yesterday who will
hear from later but he stood on the
beach yesterday with me and he said why
am I here why was I the one who got to
leave this beach and that's a question a
lot of these men still still ask at this
point gale yeah one of the one of the
notes we keep hearing recurring when you
hear from the veterans is they're not
the heroes these survivors those being
honored today it's the the men who are
underneath those crosses that we're
showing right now I'm curious have have
the veterans had the opportunity to make
a visit to the cemetery that we're
seeing behind you they've made visits
that here they've also you know it's
difficult for some of them to get around
in fact it's probably difficult for most
of them to get around but there are
points you can get down to the beach
where it's a little easier than for
example here at the cemetery where it's
almost impossible because the bluffs are
so high but you know they're for as I
said for a number of them it's actually
the first trip after 75 years and so
it's an incredibly moving experience for
them that a lot of them have brought
their families sons wives and and so
forth so it's the and they know it's
really their their last chance mark
thank you very much